so document databases are
fairly similar in concept again they
take different
rows of data and distribute them across
different machines but they're focused
on a slightly different audience they're
focused on applications
that
take
records that are fairly complex and need
to access those records in somewhat
complex ways
in some ways document is not the ideal
term for them because you're not really
storing
word documents or
documents tend to sound like something
like documentum if you think about a lot
of applications especially web
applications what a typical user does is
they'll submit a record or submit form
data and then browse the various records
in the system in various ways that's
true of a very broad class of web
applications
and what something like a mongodb will
do for you is allow you to have a lot of
different types of records
a without a lot of engineering and b
allow you to take different categories
of data and access it all in the same
way
trying to do the same in a relational
database might require you to have a
very complex schema with lots of complex
joins
whereas in a document database
it's fairly straightforward to represent
something where someone might be able to
store 80 different types of records in
one collection a document database
absolutely allows for very messy data
and one thing you need to be careful of
is a document database gives you the
ability to do extremely rapid
application development which is a
beautiful thing i'm a huge believer in
agile software development but when you
start to do it on your data tier you can
really run into some problems because
this is data that you own and are going
to have to deal with later
so
even for the most flexibly flexible
schema products it's pretty important to
consider carefully how that data is
going to be accessed and modeled
i view the more
the better use case of this
as having multiple kinds of data instead
of just incredible flexible incredibly
flexible data one example we used for
this
we had an art collection site where
users need to keep track of various art
collections which range from sculpture
to paintings to old documents to to any
kind of thing and these things have a
handful of attributes in common but are
really fundamentally very different
we used mongodb for that with a great
deal of success
you